Being a VTuber must be so easy.
WRONG!
It might look fine on the surface, but I assure you, everything can, and will go wrong at one point.
1. Your model tracking can glitch out.
2. Your audio can break overnight, even though you haven't changed a single setting from the last time you stream.
3. Your PC can and will randomly bug you to update in the middle of an emotional scene in the video game.
4. Your internet provider will decide that right before you stream to die and offer you a tiddly wink of bandwidth,
even though you pay premium rates.
5. Your audience won't be notified of the things you're up to.
Aw, thanks to the algorithm game on social media!
So you constantly get people confused when you reference an older stream that they have no idea about.
Should I keep going because I can complain all night long, Senpai?